[Música]
voy a comenzar
contándoles mi desayuno de hoy que fue
huevos fritos en mantequilla tocineta
pan y café ahora voy a darles un
segundito para que cierren los ojos
y visualicen el desayuno que tuvieron
hoy
muy bien bueno mi desayuno no fue ese
que les dije pero por ahora guarden esa
imagen que ya volveremos a ella
la verdad es que nos encanta comer
y nos vemos
sumamente influenciados por lo que otros
nos dicen sobre la alimentación para
bien o para mal
hace unos años en los eeuu casi estalla
una guerra civil cuando el presidente
george bush padre simplemente comentó
que no le gustaba el brócoli los
productores de brócoli se molestaron y
reaccionaron a tal punto
tuvo que defenderse
efe
hay de un agua franklin
el barco y wouter verbraak away
no les parece fascinante que así un
pequeñito comentario como éste fue haber
creado semejante alboroto
hace unos días curiosamente en costa
rica no se dieron cuenta pero sacaron
precisamente el brócoli de la canasta
básica pero eso no fue todo también
sacaron los garbanzos el atún las
harinas integrales y un montón de frutas
y vegetales no voy a entrar en lo que si
se quedó pero por dicha y estoy seguro
que ustedes están también muy alegres
de que
metieron productos que consumimos todos
los costarricenses regularmente como la
leche de cabra la linda de yuca el
pinolillo y hasta las hojas de plátano
lo que llamamos canasta básica
alimentaria es una verdadera vergüenza
porque esto es en serio investigadores
en el campo de la nutrición han dedicado
los últimos 40 años a determinar la
manera en que la alimentación afecta la
obesidad y las enfermedades crónicas
como la hipertensión diabetes
cardiopatías cáncer que surgieron cuando
la expectativa de vida sube de 35 a 77
años o sea se duplicó en menos de un
siglo y gracias a este esfuerzo hoy
tenemos las mejores recomendaciones
basadas en evidencia científica
pero esto no ha sido fácil ya que para
evaluar el papel que juega la dieta en
este tipo de enfermedades hay que llevar
a cabo muchos estudios en cientos de
miles de personas uno de estos
el estudio llamado nersys house star y
el estudio de las enfermeras fue
diseñado específicamente para evaluar
esto
este tipo de estudio se llama
prospectivo porque la dieta la evaluamos
cada cuatro años a través de la vida de
todos los participantes conforme la
población envejece y se van manifestando
las diferentes enfermedades podemos
volver atrás y determinar
específicamente el tipo de alimentación
que tenían las personas que por ejemplo
sufrieron un infarto
solamente este estudio incluye 274 mil
participantes tiene 40 años de haber
comenzado y ha generado más de 1500
artículos científicos documentando el
papel que juega la dieta
y la salud otro tipo de estudio como el
costa rica jacques tardi específicamente
evalúa patrones alimentarios de los
costarricenses en relación al impacto
porque aquí porque nos interesa ver
estos efectos en una zona tropical
lo que quiero que quede muy claro con
esto es que es la acumulación el
conjunto de la evidencia científica la
que se usó para
determinar las recomendaciones
alimentarias que tenemos hoy es más
según la comisión y plan ser esta es una
comisión mundial que trata de
mezclar la importancia de la dieta en la
sostenibilidad del planeta ellos indican
que el seguir estas recomendaciones es
fundamental para la salud del planeta o
sea no corran a cambiar su alimentación
porque vieron algo en las noticias hoy
porque lo leyeron en las redes sociales
ya que estos medios la industria
alimentaria los intereses políticos y
hasta los mismos profesionales en salud
interfieren en la manera en que la
evidencia científica se transmite a la
población por ejemplo en los eeuu
en el ministerio por decir el
equivalente al del departamento de
agricultura que es el
encargado de velar por los intereses de
los productores también es el encargado
de
y elaborar las guías alimentarias para
la población este conflicto de interés
resulta en recomendaciones que incluyen
la carne roja como parte de una dieta
saludable a pesar de que la evidencia
dice todo lo contrario
desafortunadamente la evidencia tampoco
se usa en otros países acá
una guía de recomendaciones del colegio
de nutricionistas y profesionales en
nutrición de costa rica
indica que consumir carne roja es
equivalente a consumir pescado
que consumir una copa de helados es
igual que consumir aguacate o aceites
vegetales otro ejemplo de esto del todo
no está apoyado por la evidencia
científica como si esto fuera poco
estamos bombardeados constantemente por
anuncios con todo tipo de dietas mágicas
todo lo que queremos creer que funciona
fuertemente influenciados a consumir
literalmente cochinadas
en costa rica
en costa rica a pesar de que tenemos la
expectativa de vida más alta en américa
latina'
tenemos una alimentación tan mala y una
vida tan sedentaria que 2 de cada 3
costarricenses tienen sobrepeso
lo más preocupante lo que a mí me
verdaderamente me preocupa es que a no
ser que haya un cambio en los subsidios
impuestos y disponibilidad de alimentos
vamos a seguir
paralizando cualquier esfuerzo que se
haga para
y combatir la obesidad enfermedades
crónicas y sus efectos en la calidad de
vida el costo de la seguridad social la
productividad y el desarrollo económico
por qué digo esto
qué es una dieta saludable
voy a usar un marco de preferencia voy a
explicar o contestar esta pregunta
usando un marco de referencia que yo
llamo el cuadro vital
los colores que se indican en este
cuadro representan una escala de salud
que va desde nocivo para la salud hasta
beneficioso para entender el cuadro si
nos referimos a la parte superior
podemos ver la frecuencia recomendada la
frecuencia de consumo recomendada por
semana y en la parte inferior va una
escala que va desde sin procesar hasta
muy procesado
voy a bueno y si dividimos este cuadro
en cuatro grupos el grupo a indica
aquellos alimentos que son saludables se
deben comer todos los días es la base de
una dieta saludable veis indica los
alimentos que si se consumen con
moderación se pueden incluir en una
dieta saludable pero no son
indispensables y en que están aquellos
alimentos que son nocivos cuyo consumo
debe limitarse porque promueven la
obesidad y las enfermedades crónicas
ahora lo que voy a hacer es
explicándoles
él
donde se ubica cada grupo de alimentos
en el cuadro
primero las frutas vegetales y verduras
no hay discusión va nena
son saludables tan de acuerdo
el azúcar postres y bebidas azucaradas
dejo
ni modo
ahora hay unos grupos de alimentos que
han causado un poco más de confusión
comencemos con las fuentes de
carbohidratos o lo que llamamos
con lo que al mente lo llamamos
carbohidratos este grupo a donde lo
ubicarían
a bs
depende
la verdad es que depende no se puede
evitar en todo un grupo si éstos están
sin procesar como el arroz integral
trigo granos integrales avena van en a
pero estos mismos alimentos van gente si
están procesados
entonces
ahí es la manera en que se prepara el
alimento otros como tortillas tubérculos
raíces como la yuca van en
veis con moderación y las grasas que
hacemos con la grasa si es aceite de
soya o canola ideales porque contienen
omega 3 van
a otros como el girasol y el oliva
también vagina
pero otro tipo de grasa como la manteca
la mantequilla van en d
las leguminosas o las proteínas o el
grupo que llamamos proteínas también es
tan diverso que no se puede incluir en
un solo grupo los que son como como los
frijoles garbanzos lentejas el yogur
pescado y hasta
[Música]
las semillas como semillas como el maní
banana totalmente del otro lado están
las carnes rojas y todo tipo de
embutidos carne res cerdo pollo
con moderación tenemos los huevos la
leche
el queso y el los el pollo
o sea para resumir debemos aumentar el
consumo de los alimentos no procesados
de origen vegetal y bajar los de origen
animal esto no es una opinión lo dice la
ciencia ahora sí volvamos al desayuno de
hoy a ver a dónde lo ubican en el cual
ahora sí
ahí va lo que yo les dije y este es mi
desayuno de hoy es cierto es mi desayuno
que estamos comiendo los costarricenses
un poco del balanceado muchos productos
en arroz blanco
pan blanco pasta carnes rojas y azúcar
esa es la mayoría de las calorías que
consumimos vienen de ahí y ven ven los
frijoles donde van para afuera
cada vez consumimos menos las porciones
son más pequeñas y muchos almuerzos ya
ni los incluyen
cómo hacemos para mejorar bueno
agregando en cantidades grandes de
vegetales y verduras en muchísimas
preparaciones con aderezos deliciosos a
base de aceites saludables
también cantidad de frijoles no solo
frijoles negros sino todo tipo garbanzos
un día lentejas otros frijoles rojos y
hay una gran variedad
tortillas
granos enteros como el arroz integral
sé que hay
muchos así como pero bueno
el postre ideal frutas semillas y
chocolate oscuro ahora si no puedo dejar
de mencionar que una dieta óptima
incluye mantenimiento de peso
desafortunadamente eso es difícil en una
sociedad sedentaria como la nuestra y
encima la cantidad que podemos consumir
disminuye con la edad entonces es que se
puede hacer que yo les voy a dar nada
más compartir lo que yo he hecho primero
moverme cada vez que pueda donde pueda
como pueda
cualquier oportunidad simplemente si
estamos sentados y nos paramos y
caminamos cien pasitos ya es algo
segundo
trato de pensar me todos los días y si
ve una tendencia como que va subiendo
año gordo hija antes de que sea muy
tarde
ya pueden imaginarse lo que eso
significa y por último voy a
compartirles un secreto' tengo este
pantalón más como un short que me pongo
de vez en cuando desde 1984
y es cierto que yo veo como
si no me queda si me lo pongo y no me
queda no compro ropa y créame que hay
momentos en que parece un retrato y ha
habido momentos porque no lo puedo
cambiar lo que tengo ok ahora tengo una
tarea para todos los que están acá se
les va a dar una imagen con el cuadro
vital y apenas llegan a la casa lo pegan
en el refri y van a comparar lo que
tienen en su casa con lo que está en el
cuadro vital y mañana se ponen el
pantalón que mejor les queda y van a
comprar la romana yo les digo es posible
mejorar nuestra calidad de vida
escogiendo cambios sostenibles no a
través de retos absurdos ya tenemos
hambre
vamos a ir a almorzar delicioso y
nutritivo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]